[Music]
kind of taking a you know mental reset
but um I'm in the mood so let's throw in
another speed on game on my Frankfurt
airport account where a lot of the
recent games have been a little bit
suspicious some of the games have been
weird like quick wins it seems like I've
been a little bit cursed but fingers
crossed hopefully we get a good one
today because I'm a little higher rated
I might be slightly more silent and
contemplative during the game and then
air out my thoughts afterward we'll see
how it goes so seeking a 15 plus 10 game
most recent game was was against someone
who was
banned yeah I mean I lost the 10 plus 5
game to a cheater so there's been a
couple of of suspicious recent games
yeah okay let's play manderly on the
green who I think is probably in the
Stream all right good luck manderly okay
E4 so as usual I'm going to play my real
opening so we start off with a sicilian
and we play into the nidorf
D6 C3 okay so this is called the delayed
alipin um it's a relatively harmless
anti- Sicilian system but it's gained a
lot of popularity recently and if black
is not prepared just like any other anti
Sicilian like the Grand Prix attack or
like the Moscow variation it can be very
very dangerous against a poorly pred
opponent but if you position your pieces
accurately black should equalize with
relatively little issues first step is
to play Knight F6 of course and one of
the appeals yeah one of the biggest
appeals of playing this line for
beginners is that Knight takes C4 loses
a piece to the very uh common trap Queen
A4 check forking the Knight and the king
I think this is probably the most
commonly missed type of fork uh in the
opening it involves like Queen A4 and
queen A5 it's a very easy move to forget
about so obviously we don't touch this
Pawn um H3 is actually not the main move
uh this is a sideline the main move as
far as I know is Bishop B2 recently the
copc system Bishop D3 has been quite
popular even Bishop B5 check I've seen
recently tried so a lot of moves here H3
I'm pretty sure that the main move is
Knight C6 here yeah Bishop D3 so this is
kind of called the copc system it's a
very weird looking move until you kind
of ask yourself what is White's followup
and then it becomes very obvious white
wants to drop the bishop back to C2 and
control the center with D4 and the two
main ways for black to fight this are
either to try to prevent D4 from
happening or to allow D4 but to position
our pieces in such a way uh that even if
white occupies the center it's doesn't
necessarily mean that white is like much
better or anything so it's a very tricky
system I will be honest I don't know in
this position what is the best what is
the top Engine line what are the top
guns play recently so we're just going
to think on our own and I'm going to
choose a setup here that's hopefully not
quite as theoretical even if it means
that we're slightly worse so I've played
this kind of set up against Magnus in in
our Blitz and bullet matches and he
always likes he always likes to push G6
and he always tends to allow white uh to
play D4 and then try to attack the
center from a distance so we're going to
do that we're going to we're going to
play the dragon setup with G6 uh
presumably our opponent is going to yeah
Bishop C2 okay Fen King Bishop G7 so are
deciding to allow D4 uh we're not going
to try to prevent that move okay because
white castled he's also giving us the
opportunity to push E5 which is another
interesting setup so I would say that
largely that the setup that we choose as
black is kind of a matter of taste it's
a matter of okay what kind of position
do you prefer what kind of position do
you tend to thrive in here I actually
really like the look of E5 I actually
really really like the look of E5
because it it highly discourages white
from pushing D4 even though d is still
possible uh because our opponent gave us
this opportunity let's push E5 creating
a bind a clamp on the D4 square and now
if white plays D4 it leads to a a big
series of Trades and at the end of those
trades uh the bishop on G7 will reopen
and once again Lord over the long
diagonal now this type of move a newer
player in like the 15600 range might
look at it and kind of frown and say
well doesn't this move have a lot of
positional drawbacks first of all we're
creating a hole on D5 second of all
aren't we blunting the bishop on G7 to
the second point I would repeat
something I've said multiple times
before which is that you should not
really think of the bishop as an
individual piece you should think of the
bishop and the pawn on E5 as a unit uh
together they're exerting influence over
the D4 Square which is the most
important Square in the position as for
the D5 Square yes it's a hole but can
white really occupy it effectively the
answer is no white cannot easily get a
knight to D5 the square itself is
defended by our knight uh so these
drawbacks are are real but the benefits
outweigh them in this particular
instance so it kind of looks like an
awkward move E5 is rarely combined with
a fian ketto but in this particular case
I like this setup and we have nice
central control too okay so our opponent
seems to be relying on the Move D3 I
don't think that at this point they're
going to go D4 although maybe you never
know D4 is still possible from White's
perspective um stoak Killa is asking
what if he goes to C4 to get the Knight
out okay so what okay white puts a
knight on C4 big deal what's what's that
Knight doing we can push it away with B5
we can push it away with Bishop B6 okay
D4 very committal decision so obviously
we take that's the whole point we take
twice doesn't really matter which piece
we take with I mean taking with the
Knight is a little bit too committal
because we can take with a pawn
presumably our opponent will recapture
and then we can decide whether we want
to play Knight takes C4 or whether we
want to keep the tension and play some
neutral move like Rook E8
so Knight takes D4 is a little bit less
smart because it commits you to trading
everything on D4 do we have to take on
D4 no but the whole purpose of this
setup was to play e takes in the event
that he pushed D4 this was the the Zen
of the setup okay so now we have to
think very deeply after they take on D4
and I'll take a little bit of time in
silence if Knight takes D4 is on the
board yeah D6 is a weakness but there's
other aspect of the position you can't
just look at one Pawn weakness and
isolation and say okay the position
sucks we have a lot of strengths we have
a development Advantage White's Queen
side is undeveloped we have a monster
powerhouse on G7 and E4 is a very
targetable Pawn yes it's well defended
but it can be easily targeted by our
Rook from the e file and as I'll show
you after the game um this type of
structure occurs in the R Lopez so I
have quite a bit of experience with it
from the black side uh and it's usually
fine for black even though yes D6 is a
target for white okay so let me think
here for a minute or
two takes takes Bishop B6 there is a a a
sequence that I'm leaning toward but I'm
trying to double check it okay so takes
takes Bishop B6 takes takes Knight G4
Queen D1 not good takes takes Queen C7
don't like it Queen B6 is an interesting
move um Rook E8 is an interesting Rook
E8 is a very interesting move actually
Rook E8 is a very very tricky move
Rook E8 Knight B5
D5 okay complicated yeah Rook E8 Knight
B5 D5 not sure what's going on there
Bishop F4 Knight takes D4 is the simpler
move Queen takes D4 and then just Bishop
E6 completing our
development simple straightforward chest
but it also doesn't cause as many
problems to White
H now this is a very difficult position
to continue properly this is why I'm
taking time huh okay yeah I've settled
on Rook E8 I've settled on Rook E8 and
I'll spell out my thoughts a little bit
more more deeply after the game but in
general I select options that keep the
tension I've talked about this before
this is a bit of a nebulous concept
keeping the tension but if there's a
choice between getting a simpler
position and keeping it more complicated
I like to keep it more complicated
because it forces the opposing side to
make decisions this is one of the most
important General pieces of advice is if
you want to defeat a higher rated player
who knows their fundamentals you want to
force them into difficult decisions and
so often that means not forcing the
action but making these kind of Cy
improving moves and now if you put
yourself in our opponent's shoes
suddenly he's got a big Choice okay do
they play Knight B5 and hit the pawn
like that do they take on C6 who does
this trade favor that has to be
evaluated do they just continue with
casual development Knight C3 also looks
fine and this is often how you get
players in this rating range to make
mistakes because they get impatient or
they don't evaluate something correctly
of course in some situations you have to
force the action this is why when I'm
like kind of agnostic between two
different options I chose the one which
passes the ball back to our opponent so
give your opponent choices particularly
if they're in time pressure this is why
the common advice is when your opponent
is in time pressure definitely don't
force the action because the hardest
thing to do in time pressure is to make
a decision
of if there's forced mate check it go
for forced mate but this is for
situations you're not totally of the
correct move okay so our opponent
correctly taking their time yeah Queen
B6 was on my radar but I didn't like
Knight takes C6 I'll talk about this
moment after the game are we worried
about Bishop A4 absolutely not Bishop A4
is just a feeble one move threat okay
Knight F3 let's talk about that after
the game yeah this is fine dropping away
the
Knight okay so now there's many options
for us we can definitely consider D5
this is the direct attempt to eradicate
the biggest weakness we can go Knight B4
try to aim for the bishop a don't like
this move as much this seems a little
bit
superficial we can continue with our
development Bishop B6 Rook C8 Etc also
don't love it D5 seems to be most to the
point here maybe it leads still no wait
D5 Ed Rook E1 yeah this is fine for us
we will'll be in the driver's seat if
the Center opens up because we have the
better pieces D5 E5 we seem to have
Knight E4 yeah my intuition is heavily
screaming pointing in the direction of
D5 and now the
complications reach kind of a peak where
either the Center opens up and if the
Center opens up my hope is that our
Superior bishop and White's lack of
Queens side development is going to make
it difficult for white to keep the
balance even if the Queens come off the
board
or if white pushes E5 again I'm really
trying to exploit White's lack of
development here by opening up the
center this is kind of a basic chess
principle just applied in a very complex
position again white has a pretty vast
Choice here e E5 Knight C3 Bishop G5
takes on E5 now very important not to
fall asleep and play Knight takes D5
that loses a piece Rook takes E8 check
and the queen is overloaded so first of
course we have to take on E1 hopefully
you're able to follow that and depending
on the way that white recaptures we will
take on D5 either with a queen or with a
knight also Queen takes D5 essentially
drops a queen to Rook takes C8 check and
then the Knight is overloaded so yeah so
definitely takes first and let's wait
for white to choose a
recapture probably our opponent is like
okay Knight takes E1 is appealing
because at least the queen is making
contact with D5 like maybe I can get a
GM to swap Queens but Queen takes E1 as
the more natural recapture because it
keeps the Knight on a developed Square
again forcing our opponent into a pretty
unpleasant decision and each of these
decisions taken alone is not a big deal
but they contribute to time pressure and
they contribute to fatigue eventually
this is how you get your opponent to
become impatient okay so what do we take
with barthol you would probably play
Queen takes D5 but Queen takes D5
doesn't make any sense to me it just
walks into Knight C3
developing with Tempo yeah so Knight
takes D5 so Knight takes D5 centralizing
the Knight opening up the diagonal and
now we discourage Knight C3 because that
ruins the queen Side Pawn structure
permanently also this Knight has a lot
of potential Knight B4 is kind of an
unpleasant thought for white maybe the
Knight gets to D3 so my estimation is
that black has a very small edge here
objectively so in other words white can
probably keep the balance with accur at
play but these open Center positions are
extremely difficult to handle for
anybody because there's just so much the
position is very undefined if that makes
sense when there's Pawns in the center
you kind of know where the play is here
you have to kind of play in an open
board and that's always difficult Bishop
B3 is an excellent move deploying the
bishop to a good Square we should also
probably develop our Bishop where do we
put it well Bishop B6 walks into the
nasty Knight G5 so I'm leaning toward
Bishop F5 it's the only other Square
that's available is there any problem
with the queen being overloaded not that
I see because Bishop F5 Bishop G5 we can
simply move our Queen up to D7 and as an
additional benefit that allows us to
deploy our Rook to E8 so okay unless I'm
missing something just Bishop F5 is
natural okay but G4 G4 is not a scary
move G4 is an extremely weakening move
yeah Bishop D3 is I mean we can even
take the Knight on B1 in an emergency
see but yeah we would presumably go
Bishop D3 I would be very very happy to
see G4 here that just seems way too
weakening intuitively also G4 we can
drop back to E6 and as I'll show after
the game in that position Knight G5 is
actually far less dangerous white is
thinking our opponent starting okay
Knight A3 so opponent continues to try
to work around all the obstacles and
bring their pieces out okay so I'm
divided here between two moves one thing
I notice is that the only feasible way
now to develop the bishop is with Tempo
Bishop G5 because if Bishop G5 were
eliminated as an opportunity then the
pawn on B2 would hang if white brought
the bishop out for example to D2 or to
G5 no Tempo so from that perspective we
could ask ourselves how can we prevent
or take the sting out of Bishop G5 so H6
comes to mind but H6 doesn't really
further the goals of our position can we
combine prophylaxis with something more
efficient how about Queen D7 getting the
queen away from The Bishop's line of
fire so then Bishop G5 we can take on B2
although that situation actually isn't
that simple because white has the very
nasty move Rook D1 hitting the Knight on
D5 why could sack the pawn and go for
the initiative okay so that complicates
things a little bit even if our opponent
doesn't find it it's not something I
want to allow so maybe maybe after Queen
D7 Bishop G5 we could just go Rook to E8
and keep bringing our pieces out Queen
C7 would blunder the Knight on D5 the
other option is to play Knight B4 but if
we play Knight db4 then we open up the
diagonal for White's Bishop so kind of
everything has a drawback here to me the
most natural still seems to be Queen D7
let's opt for this
move and we'll see what White's reaction
is I don't know if anybody was able to
follow what I just said about Bishop G5
but we'll we'll cross that bridge if we
get there yeah still looks like we're
very much in the driver's seat here
causing a lot of problems our opponent
is doing a great job of navigating them
but hopefully eventually they crack
under the pressure thank you crack crao
man for the prime very apt timing
depends on what white does if it Wass
black to move here of course the next
move is Rook E8 this should be obvious
to you even if you're a beginner I mean
there's only one piece that's not
playing and that's the rook and you know
you could bring it to an open file with
Tempo yeah the Knight on D5 is soft that
is the focal point probably of White's
counterplay but it takes a lot of skill
to directly exploit the weakness of this
Knight and most beginner players might
even play Bishop takes D5 and just say
okay let me just get this Knight off the
board but that plays right into our
hands it gives us the bishop here the
queen on D5 will be unassailable it's
almost a losing move positionally to
give away this bishop because without
this bishop white is White's position
just comes unstuck Queen D1 attacking
the Knight directly
okay so the question is do we move the
Knight or do we defend it Rook d8 Bishop
G5 doesn't look appetizing in the least
our opponent's trying to punish us for
not playing
H6 okay what else is available here
Knight C to B4 protects the Knight
Knight C to B4 actually looks pretty
lovely because it also prepares Knight
D3 and it hit it protects the other
Knight could we go Knight db4 yes but
that allows the queen trade and if
possible I'd like to avoid the queen
trade here it slightly less the pressure
on White's position although still that
end game looks very nasty for white
actually so maybe Knight db4 is a good
option as well Knight B6 also fine but a
little bit more passive than Knight db4
okay let's think for a second it's a big
decision here very tempting to just go
into a better end game here and manage
our risk very very tempting to just
squeeze the advantage in the end game
even if it's not the most interesting
option for the viewers but let's think
Knight CB4 or Knight db4 my candidate
moves here I'm really not sure about
this but we're going to go Knight CB4
we're going to keep the Queens think
YouTube watching this just let out a
collective sigh of relief no end game
for now yeah the thing is this
construction looks very in general when
you have a one Knight defending another
Knight that's a very tactically
vulnerable construction because Knights
are easy to kick but here of course
white can't play A3 there's a knight on
that square and also the biggest thing
is that Knight is coming to D3 to cut
off the queen
and notice that the situation just
continues to progressively get more and
more complicated there's so much going
on here it's very very easy to blunder
for white and White's clock continues to
dwindle so I'm trying to like put
pressure on all fronts here and bit by
bit I think our opponent is already
starting to crack I think Queen D1 was a
mistake I think the only move to keep
the relative balance was Bishop G5
that's my theory we'll check with the
engine after the game maybe every move
is a mistake we'll see yeah white is
stuck here that's the thing white is
stuck because of the be two Pawn so
nothing is really moving here for white
nothing is really moving here at all for
white okay Knight C4 I I I was sort of
expecting this move um white is trying
to eliminate this very important Bishop
but this bishop anchors our whole
position so can we avoid giving it away
can we avoid giving this bishop away
well we can sack it on H3 not the
stupidest option but I think it's on
sound we can also sandwich it on D3 and
Bishop D3 looks like a very artificial
move but it it attacks the Knight
actually so we have to tread very
carefully here now the Knight is you
know like Atlas holding the world on its
shoulders this is ripe for an
overloading tactic but I don't see one I
don't see a way that white can challenge
this Knight
effectively like Bishop takes D5 we just
play Queen takes D5 obviously we don't
play Knight takes D5 and give up the
bishop and because we are attacking
White's Knight we're not giving white
time to generate some sort of tactic
against this Knight I think okay so
Knight on D4 is currently hanging my
guess is that my opponent's next move
will force us to do quite a bit of
calculation yeah chess is a very
complicated game I also don't really
know what's going on here I'm just
banking on the fact that my pieces are
more active and eventually I think
that's going to bring us success but you
have to be very very patient
here yeah five minutes now for our
opponent not a lot of time not a lot of
time
okay people are throwing out some moves
but it's hard for me to address them
during the game because the game is
going Knight dc2 Knight A2 yeah
definitely one of these is the best move
um Bishop E3 is also likely but that is
a serious concession then we can trade
on E3 and we've weakened White's King
side quite a bit okay four and a half
minutes now yeah actually Bishop B3 is a
blunder we just play Knight takes C3 and
Bishop takes D4 wins two pawns by force
yeah let's see expecting a move soon
yeah and and for higher rated players
watching this you shouldn't just dismiss
the impact that this is having on our
opponent's clock this is part of the
strategy I mean this is how you get
people is you get them low on time and
then the mistakes start and soon our
opponent's going to start feeling the
heat on the
clock okay this is quite a long think
over 3 minutes Bishop to D2 just
blunders the Knight on D4 I don't
understand that move it doesn't address
the
threat okay
waiting okay Knight A2 after a long
think a good move okay so first question
is does white have a threat like if it
were white to move what would white do
because this will inform our decision so
you would think that the threat is
Knight takes B4 but that's not a threat
because we just recapture with a knight
and everything is safe is Bishop takes
D5 a threat that might be a bigger
problem problem for us okay that leads
to some complications but it's an
unpleasant move Bishop takes D5 it's a
move I would like to take the sting out
of so first of all Rook C8 comes to mind
because I'm also in the back of my head
I'm keeping in mind that there is a
piece that we haven't activated yet and
all things let left alone activating
that piece would be a good idea and and
the C file seems to be where the parties
are happening this is this is Greek row
so maybe we can play Rook C8 if Bishop
takes 5 maybe we can go well at the very
least we have Bishop takes C2 there but
probably Knight takes C2 is borderline
winning after Bishop takes D5 or maybe
not actually very hard for me to tell
Rook C8 Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes C2
Knight takes C2 Knight takes C2 Rook B1
white is surviving somehow Knight back
to B4 we can win a pawn there at least
we can win a
pawn and as a backup option
we can play Queen takes D5 and we can
get into a much much better end game
okay excellent I think this is a very
reasonable option that keeps the tension
applying pressure on the Knight on C2
maybe there was something more tactical
I didn't see it okay if white plays A3
we can just play Knight takes C2 A3 is
not a threatening move it just forces a
trade but that trade doesn't necessarily
favor white maybe it does maybe I didn't
give A3 the attention that it deserved
but Rook C feels very very natural this
feels like the the right place for The
Rook CU it's it's it's you know doing a
lot on the C file if that makes
sense believe it or not it's only been
19 moves this is the thing about these
very tense games is they they're a lot
shorter than you might think they are
okay Knight takes B4 we play Knight
takes B4 the Knight still protects the
bishop and again white has this problem
with the Knight on D4 my guess is that
A3 was the best move here but let's see
how the game
unfolds I mean no I don't to my
knowledge my opponent is not a GM and
playing decent is not a good bar for GM
level okay so obviously I'm anticipating
some knight move no A3 okay that seems
to be a panicky reaction let's see so
Bishop takes D4 a takes B4 uhuh Maybe
not maybe ask maybe it's a really smart
move that I didn't give enough attention
to it's probably the case actually okay
wait I have an interesting idea here I
have to calculate it
okay there's some crazy complications
here that could be wow okay that's
winning for me I just calculated a
really important line um yeah and that
will okay so Bishop takes D4 which is
probably counterintuitive to most people
most people would be very inclined if I
understand people's thinking to to take
with the queen because it gives you a
sense of security to have the queen in
the center now after AB the bishop will
be hanging except that's also a false
statement the bishop is not not hanging
because if Bishop takes F2 check but
okay congrats what do we do with that
Bishop takes F2 sacrifices don't work
King takes F2 I feel like the attack
Fizzles out quickly my idea here was to
play a pretty straightforward move Queen
to F5 attacking F2 and actually never
mind for some reason I thought Queen
takes Bishop was a thing but it's
actually not a thing because the bishop
is protected continuing to pile up the
pressure here on White's position and
trying to force more concessions already
we've weakened their Pawn structure on
the queen side already we have pressure
on F2 and the time Advantage continues
to grow all right one minute the pawn
has to be defended how does white do it
yeah this is where time starts becoming
a huge Factor Bishop E3 is the best move
I'm 100% sure white has to eliminate
this monster on D4 even if it comes at
the cost of further Pawn structure
damage that proba probably gives white
the best chances of survival but it
feels like our opponent is kind of
progressively starting to panic thank
you naname for the raid appr appreci
Queen E1 very solid move as well trying
to keep the pawn structure intact okay
now we need a money move of some sort
you know what would be very nice is if
we could play Rook E8 here probably some
people are even thinking of this move
and thinking ah Queen takes C8 Queen
takes F2 mate unfortunately Queen takes
C8 as a check so one kind of Russian
school boy type move would be to push
the king up to G s and prepare the move
R E8 but that seems slow and that seems
slow because after King G7 white brings
their Bishop out to E3 so in very
important detail after King G7 Bishop E3
if we play Bishop takes B2 the A7 Pawn
is going to hang so the move that I
really want to discourage here is Bishop
B3 because that really really
extinguishes the Flames of our
initiative can we do that well we could
play A6 and we could simp simply protect
that pawn so that when the bishop comes
out we take B2 that is just a pawn but
Pawn is better than nothing is there
anything with a little bit more Paz
let's think anything that carries a
little bit more bite than than A6 if not
we'll play A6 no king f8 is very
bad ah actually I'm not loving this but
let's go A6 Russian school boy move just
slight Improvement and also trying to
limit the activity of the Rook no Rook
C6 I think allowed potentially some
check on E8 that looked pretty nasty to
me yeah also Bishop E3 there is Rook E8
but in that position there is this very
nasty Queen sack Bishop takes D4 ton of
like very complicated details here some
of which I will unpack after the game
but look at the clock 30 seconds now for
our opponent and the Panic is going to
set in very shortly now basically
they're playing on increment Bishop B3
played okay finally we can claim a small
prize it's just a pawn but it always
just starts with a pawn and and then it
progresses Rook D1 okay now Bishop C3
comes very close to trapping the queen
but white has Bishop to back to D2 okay
but that's a start that's a start Bishop
C3 Bishop D2 forced maybe bishop back to
D4 actually because that is a nice
Square for the bishop but then white
goes back to E3 a maybe there we could
go Rook E8 Bishop takes D4 Rook E1 Rook
E1 Bishop B5 Rook E7 no don't love it
I'll show the line that I I'm
calculating there with the Queen sack
after the
game we need a very precise move here I
don't like the general placement of this
bishop on B2 it's kind of off sides so
maybe we could play okay let's start
with Bishop C3 let's see where this goes
let's start with Bishop
C3 okay now let's test our opponent with
Bishop D4 we can always repeat we can
always repeat once nothing wrong with
that it's not a draw if Bishop E3 Bishop
C3 is not a draw it's not a three-time
repetition we could make a different
move instead of Bishop D4 but at least
we're testing our opponent Bishop B3
played okay very good our opponent is
holding very nicely now there's nothing
wrong with just trading everything and
going for a pawn up end game but yeah
this big problem Rook E8 would be
amazing but there's Bishop takes D4 and
I I don't like the attack in that
resulting position maybe it's good for
black but I'm not confident that that's
good for black it feels more like a draw
than anything else
all right in that case we what do we
do
[Music]
okay okay let's go back to C through
let's play it very simple let's play it
very very simple how exactly do we play
it simple is the question okay I have an
idea
okay we can take and go Bishop
C4 but let's trade these Bishops not
what what I wanted to do but I don't see
another option to keep all the winning
chances alive now Bishop C4 is possible
and Bishop E4 is possible Bishop C2 ah
Bishop C2 might be very smart Bishop
takes C2 Queen takes C2 Rook end game
going to be very difficult for white to
defend that in time pressure very very
difficult for white to defend that in
time pressure Bishop C2 takes Queen
takes C2 that is going to be just a pawn
down position and white is going to have
to play perfectly to hold it let's do it
Bishop C2 yeah Bishop C2 forcing the
bishop trade now notice Rook C1 what is
there there there is Bishop takes B3
yeah hopefully I didn't blunder anything
here yeah I blunder G4 I realized that
actually that that might have been a
blunder that might have been a blunder
G4 might have just forced to draw yeah
but now
G4 yeah G4 actually was blundered by me
okay that was bad that was bad but our
opponent missed it and now we have to
keep torturing white now we have to keep
torturing White
how do we torture white okay first
things first I don't like the placement
of this Rook I feel like it's overstay
it's welcome on C8 let's reposition it
to a better spot on E8 yeah I made a
huge blunder here I should have gone
back to C4 I went to C2 and I forgot
about G4 we'll investigate after the
game but that was a very sloppy moment
for me but here I'm pretty confident
that we can win this with a pawn up and
seven seconds now for white okay Queen
D5 with two seconds now Queen trade in
general I like because it makes it even
harder for white to defend if you can
trade Queens on the right square and you
can hit the pawn while you're doing it
that's even better so a move that
catches my eye is Queen E4 our basic
strategy here is to create problems on
every move and again to try to force
white into making decisions with their
last couple seconds eventually the hope
is that white is going to blunder okay
here another slow move we're playing
kind of this waiting game waiting for
white to blunder Queen C5 was very
strong by the way very strong let's go
H5 improving our position slowly forcing
white into another
decision again White's clock continues
to dwindle we're not doing anything
forcing Queen D6 okay so white is kind
of staying in place I'm hesitant about
moving the Rook up because that gives
white a back rank check I don't really
want to allow any tactics but I see a
trap I see a trap let's go Rook e six
I'm hoping for a check and then Rook d8
this is the what I'm hoping for I'm
hoping okay Queen d8 check it's not the
check I was expecting because here I
don't see a clear followup for white but
that's even better now we have territory
we're threatening before this Pawn is
hard to defend and we're kind of inching
forward in this position if that makes
sense two seconds again okay what queen
D4 check white finally buckles And
Trades queens and that's excellent here
I think we're winning and we're winning
for a couple of reasons most importantly
we're up a pawn but White's King is very
poorly positioned here White's King is
cut off along the E
file so we just have to find the right
way to transform this position so of
course we could give a check in fact we
probably should start with a check and
where do we want our Rook what is the
best what is the best configuration on
the queen side this is what you need to
understand you can't just randomly
insert your Rook wherever or do you
start by advancing your king but there I
think white has Rook D7
on the other hand there we can go Rook
B6 that's actually not a bad try to
start with King F6 and see where that
takes us yeah King F6 is not a very
committal move King F6 is not a very
committal move we're keeping all of our
options open and now my intuition is
just to go King E5 yeah or to go Rook B6
for starters but King E5 seems more to
the point King E5 seems more to the
point and now Rook D7 looks like a fork
right at Fork works these two pawns but
because we have this resource Rook B6 it
was not dangerous now we're very very
close to smoking this Rook away from the
fourth Rank and Rook C6 is going to win
the game this forces a rook trade that's
it look at how our King is covering all
the important Escape squares for White's
Rook it's out of squares White's going
to give F4 check King D5 and then it's
over after the trade our King is just
too well positioned we're going to go
after the B
Pawn Yeah for check is just a spite
check we Slide Away away from the
check and that's it quick conversion
quick conversion yeah Rook C6 it doesn't
even matter what you take with you can
play BC King C6 but BC is more clinical
I think and that's it our pawns are
perfectly configured there's no pass
Pawn uh to be made on the king side and
by the time white gets the king to the
king side we'll have like two Queens on
the board alternatively we could have
played C5 made a pass Spa that way we're
not trying to conserve the tempo resigns
GG and we made 3300 uh
2300 okay I'm really really upset of
myself for missing G4 let me just get
this out of the way immediately when I
played Bishop
C2 yeah this actually should have lost
the game for me this was a blunder yeah
this this was a blunder the top engine
move was in fact Bishop C4 as I
originally
intended but I played Bishop C2 and the
point is that the queen and the Rook are
the two worst Defenders because they're
the easiest pieces to attack so here I I
completely missed G4 I just didn't see
this move and the point is that the only
way to keep the bishop defended is to
put the queen on e4 but as a result of
this move the Rook on C8 now loses the
defender remember I even mentioned Rook
C1 Bishop takes B3 and the queen defends
The Rook but after G4 Queen E4 Rook C1
suddenly black loses because the Rook is
unprotected the bishop is under Fire and
this would be interesting but now Queen
C3 also picks up the bishop so the only
thing that black can do here
okay probably I would have played the
best practical option is to play Queen
F3 you can also take on D1 and take on
B3 but here F6 is very nasty threatening
Queen H6 this is very difficult to
survive with such a pawn but I would
have played Queen F3 and black has two
pieces uh two pawns for the piece
White's King is weak it's only plus one
so it's not completely winning but after
Queen E2 yeah Queen C3
forking the bishop and the pawn okay
this is still very much a game but white
is in the driver's seat yeah I blunder
G4 okay it looks very easy when I'm
showing it to you when I'm like hand
feeding it to you but it is pretty
Elementary tactic but I guess I'm you
know not that good so G4 was missed that
should not have happened but having
gotten that out of the way let's go back
to the start yeah blunders do happen
from time to time and everybody commits
them and hopefully that
I'm getting how can you as a Grandmaster
Miss G4 I can't tell if that's a troll
question or a real question um yeah if
there's anybody watching who's under the
impression that GM's never blunder then
it must be your first day you know
playing chess which is fine yeah um okay
let me open Chess base so I can properly
look at the opening yeah I should not
have missed G4 but it is what it is GG
to our opponent okay I'm just opening up
chess bace to check out the opening and
feed you the the the best theoretical
line yeah so C3 this is the delayed
alipin why is it called the delayed
alipin
because the regular alipin is the
immediate C3 this is the alipin this is
the delayed alipin and as often happens
in chess when a move is played one move
later it leads to completely different
position so you should not compare the
delayed alapin to the regular alipin the
types of positions you get are very very
different um okay so Knight F6 is
obvious we're not going to tackle B
Bishop B2 here H3 is uh theoretical
enough to where we're going to focus on
it for this
speedrun okay so Knight C6 just
continuing to develop and there's a very
important line here if white play plays
D4 then after C takes D4 C takes D4 you
actually can take on e4 now you might
say but wait a second white plays D5
forces the Knight away and then Forks
the other Knight and the King but does
anybody know what is the crucial detail
here why does this line work out for
black you have to know this yes you are
the first to the party queen A5 check
give me the square white if blocks with
the bishop allows Knight takes D2 and
then we have time to move this Knight or
to take the pawn the main line here is
Knight C3 and you should know that in
this position there's another trap you
don't take this Pawn because after
Bishop D2 suddenly there's no check on
E5 and black drops the
piece after Knight C3 BC and I'm
checking this with the engine uh after
looks like the the new move yeah Knight
d8 seems to be what stockfish recommends
at a high level just saying I'm dropping
back keeping everything protected black
is up a pawn and White's Queen side is
in shambles there's a slight development
Advantage but we're going to work around
it um so Queen B3 for example to protect
the pawn and you just go Bishop D7
stopping Bishop B5 check I see two games
in the database both of them went Bishop
D2 W 1995 and 1998 really interesting
and apparently Queen A4 here is the best
move oh this is a very nice move it
basically forces the queen trade because
if Queen B2 suddenly we have this fork
and we win a second pawn and White's
compensation is essentially
non-existent um very very nice little
sequence there yeah Knight d8 is rare uh
Knight E5 is the known move but I think
Knight d8 is very very solid as an
alternative and B7 is defended very
important detail so D4 is bad Bishop
D3 is the main move and now yeah G6 is
the most popular response so I
remembered this correctly Bishop C2 oh
and here I uhuh yeah Bishop G7 is also
good also possible here is to play E5 I
see Carlson versus so one player who
likes to play the system with white is
jpam Jose Martinez he plays this in
almost all his Blitz Games with white
and it's a very very tricky line uh
because white wants to play D4 so here
yeah Bishop G7 is completely fine
castles is the main move and E5 is the
top computer choice so I did remember
the correct line here if white pushes D4
uh immediately then the computer just
recommends oh wow just castles just
castles um and if white plays short
Castle then you can play C takes D4 and
E5 essentially the same type of idea as
we played in the game and here the point
is that if white plays D5 where do we
put our Knight just to see if the chat
is paying attention where do we put our
Knight yeah not Knight D4 that gives up
a pawn no Knight D4 takes takes takes
and you have no effective Discovery I
don't like
this not Knight E7 nobody's said the
correct Square yet still nobody said the
correct
Square no Knight B4 yeah Knight B4 this
is like one of the main main ideas of
this line is to play Knight B4 at the
right moment in order to go after the
bishop pair because White's Bishop has
to stay anchored to the pawn uh that's
not entirely true but I'm not going to
bore you with the details of Bishop B3
and if white yields the bishop pair then
well black controls the light squares
we're happy you can play for example
Bishop D7 or you can play it like a
king's Indian you can drop your knight
back and quickly push F5
and then the bishop is brought to D7 The
Rook to C8 we have a great position here
kind of like a king's Indian
dream what I'm kind of skipping is that
white actually can play Bishop B3 and
this is a very obscure Fork that you
should remember after Knight takes E4
Queen E1 look at this queen Forks both
Knights and it looks like black drops a
piece and black does drop a piece but
for the piece you're going to get two
pawns and you're going to get a massive
initiative in the center you're going to
play Knight takes F2 and black has
Monumental compensation for the piece
this is actually a known line Knight
takes F2 yeah Queen takes
F2 Knight
D3 crazy line feda versus San there are
some GM games here now E4 and suddenly
after Queen takes E4 bang bang and B2
Falls with a fork and black is in the
driver seat here yeah amazing
line so there's actually a parallel uh
in the Kings Indian there's a line in
the English which uh I've caught a lot
of players with this so if white plays
the English against the Kings
Indian I play a line that Gary Kasparov
used to play Rook E8 so here let me
remember how this goes white goes it's
something like Rook B1 C6 B4
D5 takes takes Bishop G5 yeah and here
you play Bishop E6 and everybody gets
really excited here like oh Knight takes
E5 but who can spot the right concept
it's Queen C7 yeah forking both Knights
and again this is still very very
complicated black is not better here but
this is the the general Point these
Knight Forks are very easy to miss and
the R Lopez there's also a line there's
actually a whole concept in a lot of
lines for example let's take an an easy
illustration say white goes I don't know
C3 and black gets excited B5 Bishop B3
Knight takes C4 players often miss this
Fork against both Knights and the R
Lopez so Queen forks and Bishop Forks
against the Knight or the Knight and the
bishop can be very very easy to miss
that's the the
takeaway okay so D4 is not scary here we
play E5 Rook E1 all right fine castles
we're still following a bunch of high
level games Nakamura versus teras
sahakyan and D4 white goes for the
complications um alternatively white can
play D3 and keep as a quiet position but
this is a completely separate line and
black is totally fine here this is not
like theoretically scary hikaro has
played like this a couple times but
black can just play like Bishop E6 Queen
E7 slowly prepared D5 the position is
not that interesting so let's consider
D4 takes takes takes takes and here okay
Rook E8 16 games but it seems like the
top Engine line is what I was initially
intending Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4
and now Bishop E6
and the point of this is very very
subtle you're trying to prevent Knight
C3 who can tell me why Knight C3 is a
bad idea it didn't matter which Pawn we
would take with we could take with the E
Pawn it's the same product discovered
attack but which move pause the video if
you're watching on YouTube why is this
why is this move Knight C3
bad yes good not Knight takes E4 because
if Queen takes E4 common blunder you're
forgetting that the queen can move away
and take a piece but Knight to D5 this
is why we put the bishop on E6 otherwise
the Knight would hang now black is
better because once the queen drops back
we take we ruin White's Pawn structure
kind of like we did in the game and we
can start targeting the C3
Pawn so this line is considered to be
the main line for this reason the main
move here is actually to slide the queen
over no but that's a bad move Queen B4
is weird Queen D1 is what the top guys
play and now already D5 is very very
strong D5 E5 and Knight E4 again this
very important idea and if white plays
Bishop takes E4 then White's lack of
development really really hurts him
really really hurts him I mean if you
look at this end game the E4 Pawn is
completely Untouchable because of Rook
D1 check and because of our Bishop pair
and our excellent Rooks black is
slightly better so this is the way to
tackle the line you take on D4 you play
Bishop B6 and you prepare a quick D5
following the principle if your opponent
is underdeveloped try to open the center
instead I decided to play Rook E8 which
I think is totally fine but it gives
white the option of trading on C6 and
bringing the Knight out to C3 and if
white is able to play Knight C3 then
white has a pretty comfortable position
white is a pretty comfortable position
because it's a little bit harder for us
to push D5 uh once white completes their
development D5 stops being as effective
of a move
obviously hopefully this is making sense
but our opponent decided to ret ret
treat this allowed us to push D5 in a
very nice version and now black has
solved all of their problems for newer
players you should remember that after
E5 uh you should drop the Knight into E4
very kind of textbook reaction not
fearing again not being afraid that
you're eventually going to lose the pawn
that's completely irrelevant and if you
really want to you can just win the pawn
back by giving a check trading and
playing Knight takes C5 you have an
excellent position uh so don't be afraid
of this whole Knight E4 idea in fact
there are situations where you genuinely
sacrifice on e4 and as a result you get
like massive massive compensation let me
see if I can find an example on demand
okay so not really a example of that of
the sacrifice exactly but just to give
you a sense of the fact that this occurs
in a lot of different openings okay why
is this so one sec let me expand the
board a little bit Yeah so here for
example is a Sicilian this idea is very
typical In the Sicilian you push
D5 uh you allow E5 but now you stick the
knight in the middle and this Knight is
really really a beast on e4 in this case
we're attacking C3 and yeah this Knight
is just very very strong so this d594
stuff should be filed into your database
of typical ideas in a lot of different
openings all right so our opponent took
we traded and so we get this open Center
position
which is definitely more comfortable for
black because we have the better pieces
I went through this during the game but
Bishop B3 is a very very accurate move
this is a very impressive move just kind
of keeping the tension and applying
pressure on the Knight a lot of newer
players probably would have panicked
here with white because it's actually
really really hard to find a move um and
Bishop G5 is not scary we just slide Our
Queen over and now white has a very very
hard time defending uh the B2 the B2
pawn queen C1 we play Bishop B6
the Knight comes to B4 very nasty
position so okay Bishop B3 Bishop F5
Bishop B6 I was worried about the
prospect of Knight G5 so I decided to
put the bishop on a more active Square
hopefully that makes sense Knight A3
okay and once again Queen D7 trying to
discourage white from playing Bishop G5
but white ended up playing this move
Queen
D1 and I thought that white should play
Bishop G5 anyway and this is very very
high level but after Bishop takes B2
Rook D1 suddenly white develops a lot of
activity against this Knight on D5 and
the point is that if black plays Bishop
takes A3 you should be very careful
about any situation where your fien kto
Bishop departs it's like fien kto Square
because that creates a lot of problems
with your king side now suddenly white
has these mating ideas and white also
has a really really big initiative after
Rook takes D5 so for example Queen C7
white can actually just come back to D1
and open up the diagonal again and
suddenly your Rook doesn't have any
squares you don't have Rook d8 you don't
have Rook E8 Suddenly It's black who has
a hard time making a move and White's
got a lot of ideas here uh so remember
if you're winning a pawn don't make all
the concessions just to take a pawn try
to it's better to keep the tension and
better to keep peace activity uh than to
go after a pawn okay so Queen D1 Knight
CB4 defending the Knight this move
should make sense Knight D4 and Bishop
D3 Knight a C2 Rook C8 all of these
previous few moves keep the tension yeah
and after Knight takes before Knight
takes before Oh My Gosh there was oh wow
oh my gosh holy smokes so there were
some inaccuracies here according to the
engine but the point is black is
slightly better this whole time Knight
takes before Knight takes before White's
only move to keep equality
uh was to play Knight F3 and here the
position is objectively equal but I
would argue that after something like
Queen F5 black is still very much in the
driver seat practically
speaking um you can if you really want
to you can kind of analyze this position
with an engine on your own Knight G5
there is the move Bishop
C2 and if Bishop F7 check there's Queen
F7 The Queen Is Lost white is down a
piece and in the event of the trade you
have Knight takes C2 Rook B1 uh and now
wow Knight
A3 Rook A1 Rook E8 simply the Knight is
Untouchable you're threatening Knight C2
and Rook E1 the bishop can't move
because B2 Falls and the Rook is trapped
white is totally paralyzed that's one
interesting line but crazily enough A3
is a losing move but the idea that wins
here is insane black to play and win
black has an incredible combination here
that I completely missed I went for the
second best option just essentially
forcing white to give up a pawn but
there was a winning move here insane
move or maybe not so insane now that I
see it so it's the move yeah Bishop C2
this escaped my attention completely so
the point is Knight C2 drops the queen
because the bishop no longer controls D1
Bishop C2 is easy Knight takes C2 again
the problem with with the queen and
white loses a
piece but the line continues white plays
Queen to
F3 defending the bishop laterally Bishop
takes D4 AB looks like white is out of
the woods but now comes the second part
of the combination takes takes looks
like white is doing okay and now bang
Bishop F2 Rook takes C1 Queen D2 check
Queen takes C1 and at the end of all of
this not only is black up a pawn but
White's King is ultra exposed black is a
winning black is a winning endgame
complete
Insanity yeah so this was the winning
line Bishop C2 um I wasn't thinking
about it because I tunnel visioned I
thought okay the two candidate moves are
queen takes D4 and Bishop takes D4 I
didn't stop to consider other options
this is a very common problem where you
kind of narrow down the search almost
immediately and if I had asked myself
maybe I can look for something else I
think I would have seen Bishop C2
because it's not such a difficult move
in and of itself and my opponent might
have not found Queen F3 that's really
really hard it's easy to panic here and
just take on C2 or whatever anyways I
played like this queen F5 Queen E1 A6 I
already went over this during the game
but the point is against Bishop B3
Bishop B2 I don't want the a pawn to
hang so finally we score a pawn great
defense by our opponent to force the
bishop trade and here the important
moment where I blunder the bishop C2
should have played Bishop C4 leading
essentially to the same position but
without the blunder this check is not
dangerous because of King G7 but I
decided to blunder with Bishop C2 our
opponent missed it and this position is
not that interesting to me because is it
a draw with best computer play
absolutely white can hold this I have no
doubt about it probably even white can
trade queens and draw this end game but
come on I mean Pawn down end game black
can kind of get the king into the center
go for the B Pawn this is going to be
really really hard to to hold um and I'm
not going to analyze this end game in
the speedrun video that would be a
little bit too much uh the game itself
was very very rich so I don't want to
burden people so basically the way that
we won this is we got a rook to a better
Square we threatened the queen trade and
eventually our opponent ran out of ideas
and initiated the queen trade themselves
white should have kept the Queens on the
board with Queen D2 this would have made
our job a lot harder and we would have
continued to torture white maybe H4 you
know maybe Rook B6 somewhere to hit the
pawn you're basically combining
improving your position with creating
these annoying situations for white
maybe Rook C6 Rook C2 trying to cause
your opponent to Panic if that makes
sense this is kind of an art form so the
last thing I'll say is that there was a
very important detail white could have
done this and tried to go for checkmate
a lot of games have been turned around
with this kind of idea can anybody spot
my counter blow to this this was
actually super important for black to
see because why would you allow this
attack we have a queen trade yeah we
check on E1 and do we take on F2 no we
check on E5 and we force the queen trade
and The Rook perfectly gets to B5 this
is the ideal Square because it's both
defending and
attacking yeah so this had to be
foreseen our opponent did something
similar probably white should play F4
and try to contain the king but our
opponent collapses letting the king
through and allowing The Rook trade Last
Chance was to play Rook D7 but I am
totally positive that this is losing for
white because we have the connected
passers and our King is close enough to
the king side where we can always defend
the G Pawn so white can't gain any
traction on the king side it's not easy
to make a pass Pawn meanwhile we just
kind of push our own pass pawns and of
course in Rook end games you're always
looking for an opportunity to initiate a
favorable Rook trade until Pawn end game
that's how I found Rook C6 I was like
wait a second The Rook is out of squares
laterally if we can take away its file
then we win the game so uh Rook C6 and
that's it the game ends so does the
speedrun but thank you everybody for
watching yeah we didn't go too deeply
into like the second part of the game
but I think it was a little bit less
interesting than the first uh so
critical moments first of all we
navigated the opening pretty well got a
favorable position Rook E8 not the best
move Knight takes D4 Bishop E6 is
theoretically the better option but
Knight F3 slight in accuracy allowing us
to open the center and then slowly
putting pressure that was the theme of
the game slowly putting pressure
inducing concessions and time pressure
and eventually our opponent buckled he
did I didn't punish him properly instead
we went for the pawn and then we went
for the blunder but you kind of get the
point not the highest quality game but I
think that was pretty instructive a lot
of interesting moments to learn from
okay pretty exhausted this has been a
long stream let's call it a night here
so thanks everybody and I'll see all of
you later thanks for
[Music]
watching